could you last could you do it I know I
watch I know there's no way but did the
one that I have none of us could last is
the one in the Everglades were every
steps they took there was a water
moccasin a [ __ ] snake that could kill
them and the insects would drive me
crazy yeah they don't like me yeah they
like the [ __ ] out of my suite blood I
could do it you could do it no I think
we could last you you and I could I want
to contact the pit seven days seven days
I have thought very seriously about
signing up for Survivor being real yeah
celebrity survivor might know I wouldn't
want a celebrity survivor what just
chucking do it I don't want to a lot of
politics in that though
I know one of my best friend she was on
the first or second season she was the
second to the last guy she almost won
she almost won Yahoo what is survivor
it's the same same thing it's been
around for 20 years there's a strategy
involved yeah I know cuz survivor only
because of the slot machines you know
how they have the thing all the fear
level or the rings and I play I've made
good money on a survivor one oh yeah you
have to make allies you know you have to
sort of be liked so they don't kick you
off I could do it I could win yeah you
know who went on there is Lisa Whelchel
who played Blair from facts of life if
you recall that woman yeah she came in
second like if well Joe can do this [ __ ]
but is there I got it no you got you can
compete for food items yeah you get like
a bag of rice and like you know meters
but then how do you cook it you gotta
figure it out make it you really have to
figure yeah you're gonna Forge tools and
it's just and rapid weight loss
oh my god oh shoot coming up I'm gonna
book survivor yeah and then do the shoot
yeah I've never been fat I'll drop a
quick deity I've never been fat yeah
waiter I'm a fluctuate er ya know I
guess an Asian and I'm gonna say
something out loud I and this isn't the
honest thing the most honest thing I can
say
is that I don't know how to make rice he
can't even use a finger method the
finger methods I don't even know no
one's ever taught me no it's just how
you measure the water to rice ratio to
rice ratio using your finger it's called
a rice finger you boil it right okay
rice cooker if you're Asian
well can you boil it yes but tell me how
you would make rice on a pot without the
rice cooker okay so what I would do is I
would put rice in a pot okay all right
and put water in it okay okay
I put a little salt how much would you
raise your rights to water well here's
the thing I would go so I'll put the
rice let's see the Rice's I would I
would double it with water so you do 2
to 1 2 to 1 2 to 1 ratio like your style
outside of the box though Nobel or what
all right so a little less than yeah a
little less right and then you just boil
it until the waters gone we gotta wait
for the boil and then you got to drop
the heat so it's a slow simmer the rice
heels didn't rinse you had a soak the
rice so crazy yeah all right
you're not an Asian babe yeah I know do
you know how to make boba
ooh boba is made of what tapioca is it
really yeah I thought it was made out of
lava starch baby yeah that's a way to go
it's way in the future but do you you
don't eat meat at all no no I will tell
you this again I know no because there
is always that night that we got done
playing in San Diego and it's 12:30 and
I'm driving by I'm driving back home
there's a [ __ ] in and out on the ride
and I'm like these are the moments I
don't eat meat for this and I'll [ __ ]
oh yeah destroy it so I don't have any
like ethical issues with it I just I
feel better when I'm not eating animal
products yeah wish I could be like dairy
is the [ __ ] work Dairy is the worse
for you dairy first okay what's worse
sugar or dairy I would say dairy
really yeah because yogurt
you need some you need natural sugar
sugars are in fruit sugars are alright
as long as you're not Getti getting like
complex carbohydrates not like simple
[ __ ] but I'm saying like dairy is like
we're the only animal
first of all were the only animal in the
world that takes any kind of dairy from
another animal yeah Wow also the only
other animal that takes dairy milk from
another animal well past the age of
where we're supposed to stop taking it I
mean yeah Christmas to breastfeed for
what a couple you know and that's why
you become lactose intolerant as you get
older because that's just a natural
response to you not needing milks
[Music]